every one of these personality traits I
talked about today believe me I've made
every single one of the mistakes and I'm
going to share with you how I made that
adjustment for myself in my life to make
that transformation so eight personality
traits that repel good people out of
your life good people out of your life
number one entitlement you feel you're
entitled to something you haven't earned
to blame it's everyone's fault but yours
three grudge somebody does something to
you don't want to talk to them for five
years for victimhood mentality self-pity
always feel sorry for yourself
five selfish it's only all about you and
everybody else simply plays a role in
your life to get you what you want
six complaint seven boasting you're
better than everybody else in the world
eight know-it-all so when I talk about
this eight personality trait there is a
formula for because to me there are
three levels of awareness in life three
levels of awareness in life and I've
been in business for plenty of people to
see folks in three areas and I've been
in all three these three areas let's
talk about the lowest level of awareness
it's very simple its ego driven
everything's about you everything's
about you're the best
it's boasting it's selfish it's me only
I matter nobody wants to do business or
be friends with somebody that's all
about them forever it's one the biggest
repellents to is smart
let me explain to what smart is you
think in every room you're in you're the
smartest person in the room you're
smarter than your family you're smarter
than your parents you're smarter than
your you're smart of every single person
you meet and you may be smart you may be
very smart but it's not the highest
level of awareness let me explain to
what I mean by this for instance imagine
I'm a fighter
okay and I'm Mike Tyson and I'm the best
boxer I'm the best in the world I'm just
amazing right and I'm very smart because
I've trained with the best I'm just
great and a boom I'm smart I going to
the ring with Buster Douglas I'm not me
no boom and awesome from Buster Douglas
knocks me out ego smart it ain't the
highest level Ronda Rousey fights every
one of us is rooting for Ronda Rousey
everybody we love run most people were
rooting for Ronda Rousey but in
the interview she did what I think Jimmy
Kimmel I think is the interview she did
where she said I know what she's not
gonna be without smart me she's not
gonna be able to outsmart me she said
that in the interview she's gonna try to
catch me with a kick but I'm not gonna
let it she said this in the interview
ego smart what happens she gets caught
and boom loses the fight because it was
driven by ego smart I have got my butt
kicked so many times in history I
remember one time I was in the Army I
would say a good story here I'm in the
Army where eighteen year olds we have
nothing better to do than fight and
everybody is in a circle and we're all
fighting okay we're all fighting because
we have all this testosterone and I'm
fighting it up and I'm I'm having a
pretty good streak of good fights then
all of a sudden this guy shows up okay
this one guy shows up he's five six
hundred and twenty-five pounds and he
says I want to fight you and I said like
honestly I don't want to hurt you I
don't think it's fair and he says no I'm
I'm okay it's okay you can hit me as
hard as you want and I say no problem oh
my gosh
so imagine 200 guys around gals
everybody were in this unit everyone's
watching this fight oh he's gonna fight
bad David and we start fighting so I'm
like starting very loose and he's kind
of like doing this stuff and I noticed
he's very quick I don't know what what's
going on it was very quick all of a
sudden I go he's coming at me and I'm
doing my thing within a half a second
I'm on my back he's got my neck he's got
me on this choke hole I can't I'm locked
I can't get out of this thing he's half
my size in front of 200 people I got
humiliated by 125 pound kid in the Army
you know what it was I thought I was the
bigger guy ego I thought I could
outsmart this guy and he whupped my tail
because it was driven by me thinking I
am smarter this guy I'm stronger than
this guy and that's what leads to the
highest level the highest level to me is
wisdom wisdom is knowing you're not the
smartest guy in the world the world
doesn't revolve around you you have
about 80 years to make an impact in the
world and you're going to be replaced by
7 billion people so as important as you
think you are you're going to be
replaced by 7 billion new people that
are going to come and replace you and I
our goal is to do whatever we can
the next 60 years 50 years 40 years what
amount of time you got in your life but
just so you know if everybody in the
world is seeking the emotion of
happiness happiness is generally comes
to people who are wise it doesn't come
to the smartest people in the world it
doesn't come to ego people people are
ego driven the best relationship are
from wisdom the best friendships are
from wisdom the best business
experiences wisdom the best kids to
razor from wisdom the best communication
skills are from what everything comes
here wisdom it's the highest level to
get to it it's not easy to do because we
constantly want to fight this thinking
we're smarter than everybody in our ego
to battle by the way you're never fully
going to be a hundred percent here you
will always have a little bit of
struggle with this so this is why in
1999 when I was getting out of the army
I made a decision to pray about four
things four things I prayed for since
1999 every time I pray I ask for these
four things courage wisdom tolerance
understanding courage wisdom tolerance
understanding I've been praying about
this God give me courage wisdom
tolerance understanding why because I
didn't have any one of them I wanted
courage I wanted wisdom to make the
right choices
I wanted tolerance because people around
me were really annoying me at that time
and it was tolerance also with me and an
understanding to try my best to
understand other people it's not easy
it's taking a long time to understand
and be able to do that but this message
today is purely because as an
entrepreneur you got to realize if
you're going to do business with anybody
people are going to get to know your
personality if you're going to hire
people around you you want to keep
people around you they're going to find
out about your personality traits if you
want clients to stay with you and do
business with your long-term they're
going to find out about your personality
traits if you have partners that are
ahead of you and your ego gets in the
way of doing good business with these
partners you know it's going to come
down to your personality traits the
sooner you take an assessment you may
want to watch this video again the
sooner you take an assessment and say I
do this I do this I do I've really got
to work on this I'm really more ego
driven out more you know smart I think
I'm smart I really do think I'm smarter
than everybody I kind of work on cuz I
may be a cop with a punch I want to be
wise and I'm going to pray for courage
wisdom tolerance understanding I see
what happens to your life see how you
process issues differently in your life
moving forward anyways that's my message
the day to you and if you have any
questions comment on the bottom and if
you haven't subscribed to this channel
please do so thanks for watching